SIDELINES.
WHAT A CHRISTMAS FOR THAT YOUNG
MAN.
GOT TO LOVE IT.
>> Doris: HOW COOL IS THAT?
>> Mark: CHIOZZA DRIVES.
MISSES THE REBOUND.
ACTIVE HANDS.
ANOTHER POSSESSION FOR THE
WARRIORS.
BJELICA FROM DEEP.
McGEE WITH A REBOUND.
>> Doris: FEELS LIKE GOLDEN
STATE THROUGH THE FIRST 12
MINUTES HAVE BEEN FASTER TO THE
BALL.
>> Mark: YEAH, JUST A STEP.
JUST A STEP.
>> Doris: LEVEL OF MULTIPLE
EFFORTS.
QUICKNESS.
>> Mark: AND THERE'S GOING TO BE
A FOUL AGAINST THE WARRIORS.
JONATHAN KUMINGA, THE ROOKIE,
THAT'S HIS SECOND PERSONAL.
CHRIS PAUL SEEMS TO SCHOOL
ROOKIES ON EVERY AVAILABLE
OPPORTUNITY.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY ROOKIES I'VE
SPOKEN TO?
>> Doris: LOOK AT TESTIFY HEM
TOOK THEIR FIRST COUPLE FREE
THROWS AND GETS MORE.
SOME TEAMS WILL FINE YOU IF FOUL
CHRIS PAUL THAN